well for more on this I'm joined by
Alistair Heath who's deputy editor of
The Daily Telegraph welcome to you and
let's start shall we by looking at the
state of the bank's finances because in
short it's been quite a tough time for
HSBC in February posted a 17% slump in
profits are down to 12 point 1 billion
that's thanks in large part to a payment
of regulatory fines some other sort of
fall of 17 percent but 12 billion pound
sounds like quite a lot so what kind of
state is the band sounds like quite a
lot of money but in fact because it's
such a large bank it's really not enough
money to satisfy shareholders and
they're really demanding costs cuts and
more profits and they need it really
because of not making a good enough
return on their investment at the moment
and we talked about fines didn't we so
let's take a look at a bad because since
2011 the banks being hit by 7.3 billion
pounds worth of fines and charges as
well from regulators around the world
and alistair remind us what those fines
were for yes I mean easily massive fines
there be many different kinds of fines
has been a there's PPI miss telling the
UK for example that's been a big
contributor to these fines there was a
massive scandal involving the bank's
mexican arm about money laundering that
that division wasn't strict enough when
it came to controlling where money came
from and you've had a more recent
scandal in twisted and involving you
know behavior a few years ago about
whether customers pay their taxes or not
so lots of fines there but also we've
got the banking levy as well haven't we
because this is cost hsbc 729 million
pounds last year and that was on top of
new industry rules on ring-fencing
retail banks from the more risky
investment bank divisions and all of
those thefts Alistair were in the
aftermath of the financial crisis
weren't they designed to protect
customers and also to penalize the bank
as well well there are two different
kinds of rules here the first was a
banking led which is basically tax on
banks that are based in the UK and of
course HSBC is furious about this
because they were never bailed out so
yes they were fine for various things
but they were never bailed out they were
not like Lehman Brothers at all they
were very secure Bank in the run-up to
the crisis yet they're still being
hammered more than anybody else really
by this text because of such a large
global bank but based in London and of
course you've also had the ring-fencing
situation now that's different that's
part of a attempt at making banks safer
but
a controversial attempt because there's
more than one way to make Bank safer and
the UK has decided to tick every box
here and that is costing UK banks a lot
of money and pushing up things for EE
like mortgage costs and so on let's take
a look at the contribution that the bank
makes to the economy because while many
may not sympathize with the bankers they
would argue that their contribution to
the economy is essential for the
country's prosperity in 2014 financial
and insurance services contributed
around 127 billion to the UK economy as
you can see there's 8% of the UK's GDP
on top of that the sector employs over a
million people a contribution to jobs of
around 3.4 percent so it sounds like an
awful lot or what would the consequences
be then of HSBC moving its headquarters
abroad as far as money to the Treasury
there's no doubt whatsoever their
financial services in general and
banking particular very very important
to the UK the really important our
economy and also to the city in to
London and they create not only these
you know this GDP talked about and also
lots and lots of tax revenues huge
amounts of money for the chance to sell
it's really dangerous for the UK if
large banks start to move out of this
country now in terms of jobs you
wouldn't see that big a difference
because HSBC can relocate to Hong Kong
for example by merely moving five
hundred people a thousand people out of
the UK that's not where the big job cuts
are going to come from the jobs cuts are
coming from the fact they going to
president branches that the automating
procedures and they're just really
having to hunt for cost reductions but
it would be a really big negative signal
for the UK were HSBC to leave okay and
but also the bank the second look it's
paid a fair amount in tax as well hasn't
it though some would argue not enough at
67,000 as billion pounds rather in taxes
and that came in corporation tax income
tax national insurance as well as the
banking levy and that's over a tenth of
total UK government tax receipts and the
banking sector alone contributed
twenty-one billion pounds so there's a
sense that while the banking Liberty
raises money for the Treasury there was
also this question of fairness at the
sense that the taxpayer should be paid
back
to the bailouts but HSBC would argue we
didn't ask for a bailout well
starvation's BC wasn't bailout so you
know they're being hit by this tanks but
the problem is not really that the
problem is whether you think this huge
tax burden facing banks is fair or not
fair if banks start to leave the UK they
get to start paying less tax because
there's going to be less taxable
activity here that's giving fewer jobs
here and you know the headquarters won't
be here anymore so they won't pay as
much or any of this banking live anymore
so that's really the question the
question is is no number one really of
choice it's not so much a particular
choice but of political reality will
banks start to leave the UK will hsbc
leave the UK with other banks i Standard
Chartered leave the UK and that would
damage our tax revenues and our tax base
so that's why it's so important for the
government to look at this really really
closely okay